that's Cheech and Chong of course in a
clip from their 1978 hit up in smoke
while the duo stoner comedy was
decidedly silly their financial success
allowed Cheech Marin to pursue a serious
passion collecting Chicano art now some
30 years after he bought his first
painting Cheech is about to have his own
museum the first in the country to focus
solely on Mexican American art and
culture when did you start collecting I
started cleaning Chicano paintings
around 1985 Cheech Marin s collection
considered the finest in private hands
in the country will soon have a
permanent home in Riverside California
the LA suburb with a population that's
more than 50% Latino offered to convert
this building into the Cheech Marin
Museum of Chicano art culture and
industry as soon as I kind of realized
what they were talking about I'm like
wow here's collection some 700 pieces is
constantly expanding Chicano art is not
a a way of painting like say the
impressionist it's more of a flavor you
get the support of this community how it
smells how it tastes how it how it feels
when you touch it this is the dela Torre
Brothers so this is all guys this is
resin everywhere you look in his Pacific
Palisades home there's another
expression of the Chicano art movement
by Mexican American artists like Carlos
Almaraz Carlos Alvarez is the John
Coltrane of American contemporary
painters I'm of the opinion that
paintings are alive and they're imbued
with the creative spirit of
of the artist and every time you walk by
them it affects you physically and
you're changed by it
hey man am i driving okay most people
know Richard Cheech Marin of course from
the cannabis infused comedy team Cheech
and Chong what's your name
[Music]
extremely sophisticated under the guise
of being these dummies their success
brought Cheech financial rewards so he
invested in his passion art this is a
badass painting yeah it really is this
work on paper is by a painter and
printmaker who goes by the name Gronk
Cheech has more than 50 works by Gronk
he was like the first Chicano abstract
artist my mantra has been that you can't
love or hate Chicano art unless you see
it Cheech plans to take an active role
in the management of his museum but the
City of Riverside still needs to raise
three million dollars to convert the
building we can accomplish this because
everybody wants to be a part of it
cool alongside Cheech is vast art
collection
the new museum plans a permanent exhibit
celebrating his career and legacy the
[Music]
actor and comedian continues to tour
with Tommy Chang now he's looking
forward to sharing his artistic spirit
the museum and Riverside the cheetahs we
call it it's going to be world-famous
and I think it will be one of the really
cool things about this he was able to
buy a lot of these paintings when when
there was not a big market for this
stuff so he got him cheap right but he's
never sold a single one Wow he loves it
so much I love an amazing collection I
loved what he said can't love her hey
Chicano art unless you see it it's very
appropriate